[Música]
mi historia comienza en el suelo
estas charlas tratan sobre los primeros
pasos los primeros pasos en cualquiera
de sus formas y las variables que mi
vida está llena de primeros pasos
soy profesor de interpretación mis
alumnos dan todos los días esos primeros
pasos
pero cuando uno quiere dar un primer
paso lo primero que tiene que hacer
las preguntas
por eso una historia empieza en el suelo
del baño de mujeres de un salón de
juegos en el barrio de moratalaz en
madrid
yo estoy en el suelo atado de pies y
manos con bridas
en frente en el baño de hombres hay un
polaco enorme con con un tatuaje de una
araña en el cuello
y un señor mayor jugador con un anillo
muy grande en el dedo
son clientes están atados de pies y
manos como yo
están atracando en lugar
tengo 28 años y de fondo suena en un
móvil zapatillas del canto del loco'
he pensado mucho si contarles esta
historia
ya volverán
no estoy seguro de lo que voy a lo que
voy a contarles es una idea nueva y
original y se preguntarán ustedes
entonces que hacen aquí escuchándome
pues les prometo que yo pienso
exactamente lo mismo
pero la respuesta que puedo darles ahora
es la misma limitada durante muchos años
y es comunicar entrar en contacto con
mis semejantes o sea ustedes
para compartir una zona y simple idea se
ha estado haciendo durante miles de años
mucho antes de que existieran los focos
los cines kinépolis el sálvame el ser
humano se reunía alrededor del fuego y
se contaban historias fingiendo que
sucedían en ese mismo momento y así era
el orador narraba por ejemplo una
cacería y si lo hacía bien los demás la
veían en el interior de sus cabezas un
gran amigo mío dice que el teatro sucede
en el interior de las cabezas del
espectador que el escenario es
son un estímulo
en 4 existe desde hace desde el
principio de los tiempos la narración de
la cacería ya podría ser considerada
teatro y en un principio fue el brujo o
el chamán los chavales de los sitios
trabajos que salen todas las mañanas al
amanecer y corren por el prado nombrando
cada cosa que ver a su alrededor lo
hacen porque creen que si el brujo no
sale todas las mañanas nombrando todas
las cosas que ve a su alrededor las
cosas dejarán de existir
así que ya saben que si ustedes están
hoy aquí es porque un viejo trabajo sabe
sus nombres
las cosas no existen hasta que no se las
nombra acaso el teatro sea una forma de
nombrar una y otra vez las mismas cosas
para que puedan seguir existiendo cosas
como el amor como la muerte el dolor
pero decía que el brujo es probablemente
el primer actor canta y baila para
atraer la lluvia o la caza se para
pociones para curar el cuerpo y el
espíritu porque es probable que hace
mucho tiempo fueran la misma cosa cura
imaginemos lo que debería ser para
nuestros antepasados que un cuerpo de
repente dejar de moverse y ya no mirará
nos reguera nos faltará
sencillamente se quedará quieto
y empezar a pudrirse
la muerte era un ministerio confuso y
terrible
pero el ser humano empieza a preguntarse
cosas ya ti que palabras para hacer lo
que es la muerte quién soy que soy
porque soy porque yo lo que es llorar
sólo vivir es una suerte diaria y el
mundo se nos presenta poderoso y
terrible un volcán un desprendimiento
inundaciones sequía ausencia de caza
da miedo y todo lo que da miedo se vence
con el conocimiento así nace la
filosofía de las matemáticas la política
la física es nuestro intento desesperado
por controlar el azar y el caos y el
teatro el nacimiento del teatro nace
prácticamente al mismo tiempo que el de
la democracia
el ser humano empieza a reflexionar
sobre el ser humano y hoy casi tres mil
años después seguimos preguntándonos las
mismas cosas
cuando empecé a enseñar teatro no
pretendían además que mis alumnos fueran
estupendos actores y actrices tenía
sobre todas las cosas no ser capaz de
prepararles para el mundo profesional
querían que el talento que portaban no
fuera obstaculizado por su formación
sino que esa formación les hiciera volar
y alcanzar cuantas metas se propusiera
escurrir dos cosas
la primera es que el talento es una
chorrada de proporciones bíblicas
si bien debe de existir no lo pongo en
duda no creo que haya nadie con la
capacidad para detectarlo todos aquellos
que se vanaglorian de haber descubiertos
grandes estrellas lo hacen por intentar
atrapar una migaja del talento de verdad
nadie puede saber lo que hay dentro de
otro ser humano que todavía no ha sido
revelado
sin embargo hacemos negocio con ello
imaginamos lo que debe tener una
estrella nos planteamos mística leyenda
parece que queremos ignorar la verdad
el trabajo la inteligencia la
sensibilidad a mentía el tesón son
cualidades medibles inmejorables
he visto multitud de chavales y chavalas
por las que nadie ha dado un duro
convertirse en artistas de primer nivel
la historia está llena de sonrojantes tú
no vales tú no tienes eso tú no tienes
por ejemplo presencia escénica y eso no
se aprende
todo se puede aprender solo puede costar
más o menos esfuerzo puede ser más o
menos fácil pero se puede aprender
preocuparse por el talento es con todo
lo que hay que mejorar de uno mismo es
como preocuparse por si va a llover no
es algo que puedas controlar y de nuevo
entra el brujo en escena intentar
controlar el azar y el caos
la segunda cosa que aprendí es que todo
tiene un efecto más allá de sí mismo me
explico yo quería ser quería que mis
alumnos aprendieran a interpretar a ser
actores y actrices quería ser un
profesor respetado exigente meterles en
la cabeza la importancia de la
disciplina en nuestro arte
quería a trasladarles la importancia del
escenario del respeto a las tablas y yo
tenía que transmitirlo por supuesto todo
esto es importante por supuesto pero no
es lo único
para enseñar también hay que escuchar y
sobre todo comprender no se puede
enseñar aquí no se comprende
a veces al mes a alguien que piensas que
no puede ser actor o actriz dichoso
talento
y te das cuenta de que guarda en el
pasado algo que le bloquea
si descubres que es
y la ayudas a desbloquear lo puede pasar
lo impensable
yo tenía una luna que siempre que
interpretaba estaba triste siempre
me daba igual el personaje que
interpretará el resultados que los
monólogos o escenas que hacía eran
aburridos faltos de energía faltos de
ritmo
yo le intentaba enseñar toda la todo lo
que es la técnica pues no ponéis tanto
agonista deseo razones de intenciones
subtexto nada
no tendría talento
un día entra en mi despacho me dice que
tanto ella como yo sabemos
que ella es carne de cañón
pero que su madre había muerto su padre
estaba en la cárcel y era pobre la mayor
parte de sus novios la maltrato
estaba condenada al fracaso y a la
infelicidad
esta chica no se le caían los personajes
o no actuaba bien o río turia talento o
porque no fuera mala actriz
no le salían porque estaba triste
porque estaba triste y no confiaba en sí
mismo
durante tres años trabajamos con tesón
sobre el autoconocimiento su
autoconocimiento y la asunción de sí
mismo se aprendió a respetarse y amar lo
que hacía y hoy es una actriz que ya no
sé lo que hace cuando interpreta pero
ese es quizá el mayor orgullo que tiene
un profesor de interpretación tener la
pista de lo que hace tu alumno para
hacerlo también
decía el principio que todo tiene un
efecto más allá de sí mismo
al efecto al que me refiero es que mis
alumnos mientras aprendían a interpretar
aprendían también a conocerse a sí
mismos así que con concierto pasmo a sus
historias de cambio a veces ellos tenían
emociones que no conseguían controlar y
ahora al conocer sus fuentes eran
capaces de canalizar las y controlarlas
aprendí que no todo es lo que parece que
debajo de conductas desagradables a
veces hay un miedo profundo que hace que
alejemos de las personas que amamos
aprenden a no juzgar al personaje que
para eso están los jueces nosotros con
nuestros comportamientos para poder
encarnar los
entienden que el arte y el buen teatro
en general ayudan a generar criterio y
que el criterio está emparentado
íntimamente con la libertad porque nadie
es completamente libre si no consigue
generar un criterio propio
y ahora toca volver
al salón de juegos al baño del salón de
juegos
llevaba un año trabajando tanto cambio a
los clientes que jugaban a las máquinas
y ayudándoles a jugar a las máquinas
estuve durante meses en un sitio donde
si lo hacía muy bien lo máximo que podía
conseguir era fabricar ludópatas
tardé años en librarme de esa culpa
y liberarme de esas caras
que deje atrás y que siguen jugando
cuando me marche
con una de las que nos invalida que es
la cara de aquí el polaco enorme que me
da muchísimo miedo con el tatuaje en
forma de araña en el cuello
me da muchísimo miedo porque cada vez me
pedía cambio lo hacía con muchísimo
desdén con mucha violencia además era
enorme con unos músculos enormes y
malencarado mucho miedo
estaba allí cuando entraron los tres
atracadores
estaba el polaco el señor del anillo mi
compañero y yo
el sonido del arma al cargarse eso es lo
que no se me va a olvidar nunca
nos hicieron escuchado alguna vez
al cliente mayor y al polaco nos
metieron en el baño de hombres y a mí en
el de mujeres y mi compañero se lo
llevaron para que le saliera de la casa
fuerte y las máquinas tragaperras
lo único que yo no quería que sonara lo
que más tenía que sonar en un disparo de
repente
la muerte es tan cabrona que incluso te
quita el derecho de cargarte en ella una
vez muerto
sencillamente negro
sí
en aquello seguro que se podrán imaginar
en un montón de cosas pensé en mi
mujeres
pensé en que no creía en dios y que
aquel episodio era una manera de poder
tratarlo
pensé en el teatro
pensé en que estaba haciendo yo ahí
pensé en cuánta culpa era capaz de
esquivar antes de hacer algo bueno con
ella
y estaba en todas esas cuando de repente
hoy al polaco llorar
como un niño
un tío grande como una montaña lloraba
como si se fuera a deshacer
eso no mucho si contarles esto porque no
estoy seguro de que este sea mi primer
paso tengo la sensación de que todos los
pasos que da una persona a lo largo de
su vida son en realidad un primer paso
muy grande
pero siempre que pienso porque soy
profesor
me viene a salir de una manera o de otra
y me miren la cara de aquel polaco
pienso que me daba tanto miedo porque
tenía tanto que tenía que dar
y que al dar miedo a otro se sentía
fuerte y por tanto sin miedo
a veces pienso que vamos por la vida
muertos de miedo los unos de los otros y
que ponemos todo nuestro empeño en
fingir que no lo tenemos
vivimos en un mundo rápido raro con
muchedumbres enfadadas y enfrentadas un
mundo donde parar y reflexionar
da pánico las emociones corren
despavoridas y pasan desde la tristeza
al miedo del miedo al enfado del enfado
a la ira de la ira a la violencia y creo
sinceramente que no debemos dejar que
nos roben nuestras propias emociones no
debemos dejar
y que nos hagan dejar de creer en un
futuro que no los haga más dedicados y
sí más felices
si no subimos la verdad que duele y que
hay dentro de nosotros
y tuvimos el dolor de esa verdad para
refugiar nos en la mentira sencillamente
porque pensamos que es lo único que nos
puede mantener en pie si dejamos que nos
roben nuestras emociones ignorando las
nuestras las reales sencillamente porque
es más fácil estar enfadado que triste
entonces dejamos de dar pasos hacia
nuestra propia felicidad
vamos por el mundo con las cabezas
cargadas como armas
vivimos con ellas cargadas amamos con
ellas cargadas tenemos hijos con ellas
cargadas y a nuestro alrededor hay tanto
miedo
hay crisis climáticas
hay gente sin hogar
hay guerras hay separaciones hay
tensiones políticas globales tensiones
políticas locales en realidad nuestro
mundo no se es no es tan distinto desde
nuestros antepasados sigue habiendo
volcanes
el teatro del que yo creo el que intento
transmitir a mis alumnos es un teatro
que debería pagar el mundo para poder
reflexionar colocar un espejo delante
del espectador un espejo que le haga
mirarse a sí mismo y a los demás un
espejo que le haga conocerse a sí mismo
y cuentos conectándonos con la verdad de
las cosas
el teatro debería sacar el miedo de cada
uno de nosotros para ponerlo en común y
así exorcizarlo
comunicándonos estableciendo un diálogo
que nos haga más valientes más sensibles
más sabios más inteligentes
en definitiva
mejores seres humanos
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]